now former president Donald J Trump has
been indicted by a criminal court in New
York City he will be arraigned in
Manhattan at some point next week we are
told that will likely be Tuesday fake
news CNN is reporting that he could face
over 30 charges uh in a statement uh
Trump is saying quote political
persecution and election interference at
the highest level in history from the
time I came down the golden escalator at
Trump Tower and even before I was sworn
in as your President of the U.S the
radical left Democrats the enemy of the
hard-working men and women of this
country they have been engaged in a
Witch Hunt to destroy the make America
great again movement now you remember it
just like I do Russia Russia Russia the
Mueller hoax Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine
impeachment hoax one impeachment hoax 2
the illegal and unconstitutional
Mar-A-Lago raid and now this he's right
after years of partisan would which
hunts Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg he has
literally thrown the rule of law to the
wind in exchange for a cheap Act of
petty political Vengeance and he has
brought the criminalization of political
differences now to an entire new level
this is repulsive it's a disgusting
political hit job the likes of which we
have never seen in this country it's
never happened before now Pandora's Box
has now officially been opened we have a
new era of political revenge and a
weaponized justice system is now upon
all of us and tonight the exact charges
they're saying as many as 34 they're not
known but they seem to be stemming from
what is a convoluted so-called what we
call novel legal theory used by far left
D.A Alvin Bragg to criminalize what a
non-disclosure agreement from seven
years ago passed the statute of
limitations
investigated to death rejected by the
doj by the Mueller investigation the FEC
Bragg's predecessor and even initially
by Bragg himself this is not a strong
case by any stretch of the imagination
and frankly no fair honest or honorable
D.A whatever bring these charges or in
the words the infamous words of James
Comey no reasonable prosecutor would
ever prosecute such a petty and weak
case but a grand jury can indict as we
say a ham sandwich especially if that
ham sandwich is Donald J Trump and the
grand jury is comprised of what liberal
New Yorkers the only conservative ones
are right here in studio with me
keep in mind keep in mind the defense
a lot of people don't know this so and
uh this is basic and I know people are
busy with the day-to-day lives the
defense and a grand jury they do not get
any opportunity at all whatsoever to
present any case they don't get any
opportunity to put forward any evidence
uh in Grand Jury proceedings the defense
does not get to present anything to a
grand jury hence she can indicted ham
sandwich and you better believe the D.A
Alvin Bragg excluded a mountain of
exculpatory evidence from this grand
jury clearly Bragg has a political
agenda Justice is not blind in New York
City in Manhattan in fact in 2021 look
at this Alvin Bragg campaigned on a
promise to go after one man Donald Trump
one organization and that is the Trump
organization one family and that is the
Trump family in other words you show me
the man and guess what I'll find the
crime and that was the Mantra of the
former Soviet Union this is a pathetic
case it is deeply unethical frankly
anti-American this is not equal justice
under the law this is not equal
application of our laws but here we are
thanks to New York City and its far left
radical D.A Bragg and watches great
campaign
a lot of people are wondering uh whoever
has this job
are they going to convict Donald Trump
look that that that is uh the number one
issue I'm the candidate in the race who
has the experience with with Donald
Trump I was the chief Deputy in the
Attorney General's office we sued the
Trump Administration over a hundred
times I'd be hard to argue with the fact
that that's that'd be the most important
uh most high profile case and I've seen
them up front and seen the lawlessness
that he can do and you believe it should
happen
I believe we have to hold them
accountable
all right today Alvin Brad guess what he
just fulfilled that campaign promise he
is not upholding the rule of law by the
way imagine electing a D.A that is
promising to go after one man one
organization one family he doesn't seem
to give a rip about the real rule of law
he this is a guy that has led killers
and rapists Go free on a regular basis
uh he is now bringing a far-fetched case
against Donald Trump yes it's insane yes
it's crazy but this is life in America
under radical leftist new green deal
climate alarmists cultists and here's
what former FEC chairman Brad Smith said
right here on this program last week
take a look
most of us would not think that it is a
campaign expenditure to try to settle
potential legal claims against you or
other claims against you for events that
occurred ten years before you talked
about running for for office you know to
pay allegedly to pay hush money to to
Stormy Daniels or any anybody else I
think it's a common sense matter most
Americans don't think that's a campaign
expense and the odd theory of of the D.A
brag is that not only could those
expenses be paid with campaign funds
they would have to be paid with campaign
funds I think again it's a common sense
matter that's clearly wrong but also
when you look at the statute and you
realize that's an objective standard
it's clearly not correct to say that
these were funds that count as a
campaign expenditure but I think the
correct answer is there's no violation
here as it stands now of course Bragg's
case doesn't just have a legal problem
it also has a credibility problem now
the D.A star witness a convicted felon
tax cheat admitted Liar by the name of
Michael Cohn but don't take it from me
here's cohn's former legal advisor Bob
Costello when I interviewed him take a
look
what do you have on Donald Trump and
that's when he started with the same
litany that he used for the rest of the
two hours I swear to God Bob I don't
have anything on Donald Trump but the
point is when somebody is is really
thinking of committing suicide and
you're offering them a legal way out of
this if he had any information about
Donald Trump that would have been the
one time even for a Serial liar like
Michael Cohen to to fess up and say well
I know this or that because I'm I want
to save my own hide but he didn't do
that Michael Cohn who as I said before
was pacing back and forth would suddenly
stop in the middle of whatever he was
talking about and turn and point his
finger at us and say I want you guys to
understand I will do whatever the f I
have to do I will never spend a day in
jail he said that at least 10 to 20
times during that two-hour period it was
it was a bizarre Mantra but it made it
clear to us that Michael Cohn was saying
I will lie cheat steal shoot someone I
will never spend a day in jail
oh so uh Costello says Michael Cohn
admits he had nothing on Donald Trump
and that he would do whatever it takes
to get himself and prevent himself from
going to jail now not only did Costello
destroy the credibility of their star
witness Picone himself completely
contradicted the state's case with this
statement from 2018 from his lawyer in a
private transaction in 2016 I use my own
personal funds to facilitate a payment
of a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
to miss Stephanie Clifford AKA Stormy
Daniels neither the Trump organization
or the Trump campaign was a party to the
transaction the payment to miss Clifford
was lawful was not a campaign
contribution or a campaign expenditure
by anyone now a Cohn attorney echoed
those remarks in a letter to the FEC
quote in a private transaction in 2016
before the U.S presidential election Mr
Cohen used his own personal funds to
facilitate a payment of a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars to miss
Stephanie Clifford neither the Trump
organization or the Trump campaign was a
party to the transaction with Miss
Clifford and according to the Washington
Post TMZ other outlets Stormy Daniels
has actually denied in writing the
affair multiple times and writing on for
example January 30th of 2018 quote I am
not denying this affair because I was
paid quote hush money I'm denying this
affair because it never happened and her
signature so let me get this straight
the D.A in New York and Manhattan Alvin
Bragg dedicated thousands and thousands
of hours millions of tax dollars to a
case surrounding what is a legal NDA
over an alleged Affair from 2007 that
both parties deny by the way and based
on allegations from a admitted convicted
felon admitted liar Michael Cohn who is
hell-bent and has been hell-bent for a
while on getting revenge against his
former boss look make no mistake this is
not about a an NDA a non-disclosure
agreement from 2016. instead what we are
witnessing is a far left prosecutor
attempting to smear Donald Trump for
political and personal gain ahead of the
2024 elections watch this
and even people that don't like me are
saying this is a terrible thing to do
for a country I don't know whether it
helps or hurts I can tell you in my
opinion it's a new way of cheating on
elections it's called election
interference what they're doing is if
they can't win at The Ballot Box because
I'm leading Everybody by a lot in the
polls for every Republican frankly and
every Democrat by a lot including Biden
by a lot and they can't beat you that
way they're going to do this kind of
stuff this is uh never been done like
this before in the history of our
country to this extent people are
pleading with the prosecutor don't do it
don't do it it's wrong even Democrats
even people that traditionally are not
exactly my fans are saying don't do it
because I didn't do anything wrong I did
nothing wrong Glenn yonkin is supporting
president Trump Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is calling the Trump indictment
quote Un-American and announced that
Florida will not cooperate with any
extradition effort hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else